[Musik]
die meldung raus
eine schokolade ist angekündigt ich habe
alles abgeklappert und eine vertreten
habe ich mir gedacht ich koche etwas
pizza trocknet hat weg so und troicki
vor und ich hoffe minuten für den
normalen fixerutensilien und machen eine
eigene schokolade place mit loriot im
westen unter dafür nichts davon ich
würde sagen kann jetzt noch mal einen
blick auf wir haben jetzt weit
verschiedene packungen mit dort am 8 und
weil diese noch nicht schlagfertiger
zeigt es doch einfach viel rauch für
zubereitung inhalt eines häufig in eine
schüssel geben 150 millilitern wasser
dazugeben und dann verspielten leute ich
dachte okay das ist ein ganz lustiges
video bezahlt als direktes insider
machen womit verhageln die sondern
überleben als 100 ml für noch mehr ihren
gedachten sie einfach die ganzen die
langfinger
das spart eine ewigkeit bitte formen
oder chattet mit zeigt für mich viel
spitze weg wie mein name höheren
verhindert luca bis dahin einfach die
entwicklung gerade pizzateig mischungen
mit wasser angeboten gehört
da frage ich nicht wo das noch mitmachen
für die weinstädter verbrauchen würde
nicht so nein aber ich glaube wir können
jetzt einfach das ganze leben auf den
kopf stellen und wir haben damit aber
bei der komplett bestritten
nochmal bleibt aber es ist also
chronisch das nein oder dass die
körnchen drauf also endlich wer stark
nach brötchen zeit gerade und
allgemeiner kleine brötchen gebacken
werden aber welchen
mit technisch sogar die zweite ganz
einfach anfangen mit der schokolade zu
sagen
den zeitlichen damit wir brauchen die
zeit um eine verschwörung auf den weg
[Musik]
mit spaßigen teile video als allererstes
nehmen wir doch einen fehler und leute
typische kindern einfach
ich war eigentlich lieber mensch der
einfach nur apple konnte aber wir wissen
möchten
stimmt die schöne klettern im keller ein
bisschen über die pizza und nach wieder
mal wieder ab wir eigentlich einer
normalen etwa als tomatensoße abstempeln
würden das kino zeller und glaube dass
elektrogeräte drauf klatschen werde
bekommt endlich kann man alles beim
schick machen ich weiß nicht wie nach
einer open auf dem man arbeite ich damit
ist ford mit ja auch viel von den
fehlern
dafür erscheint wahrscheinlich mehr
experten rufen jetzt einfach mal vor ich
würde sagen für grad auf jeden fall ober
unterhitze als nächsten schritt nehme
jetzt einfach mal diese spielarten
streife und erbitten über die achter ist
eine öffnung zu übernehmen jetzt einfach
wieder so bestreuen und nochmal danke an
markt für diese idee em und freue mich
einfach mal ein bisschen über die pid
wäre das heißt wir haben jetzt in utah
laderaum von sonja schokostreusel am
start und als nebel choreo wir nehmen
jetzt die orion packen wir nochmal für
uns auch dass orte drauf weil nur mit
schokolade und endlich meine story von
margherita gerade und wer kauft sich
immer gerieten mitunter laden haben kann
in salami daraufhin mit filmen wie
packen die fonds aus und das allererste
leute machen die pizza brechen die ohren
einfach noch ein bisschen deutschland
packen geht ein bisschen auf jede stelle
der pitbull aber eines ist nur mit
nutella hat nun mit zukäufen thorium wer
uns noch nicht zu viel denn wir haben ja
noch kinder schokolade meine der amon er
dem paket einfach mal von riegel hiervon
aus und brechen ein bisschen ab und an
ein paar stückchen auch die bisher auf
einen laden aufmachen wo wir verkaufen
machen glaubt öfter
kinder schokoladenstückchen drauf und
wachs hatte gerade noch eine super in
die mitte kommen könnte und immer wenn
man air berlin liegt kriegt man am ende
gewonnen und ich nehme die übermittlung
packt ihn von möglichkeiten bei mir
zuhause deswegen würde ich sagen dass
herd kommt hier in die mitte von der
pizza natürlich wieder nicht so brettin
die vom land oder so aber jetzt wird auf
jeden fall keine davon heute machen den
backofen auf das blatt mit der pizza in
den backofen und jetzt würde ich sagen
warten wir einmal 20 bis 30 minuten dann
wird wieder nur wenige minuten später
okay leute italien kam
wir schauen jetzt einfach mal ab wird
der hitze drinnen gehe ich würde sagen
wie sie sogar sehr sehr gut aussieht
eigentlich mehr auf den kuchen von dem
herz kann man sich gar nicht mehr kennen
[Gelächter]
dr einfach in der mitte ein bisschen
authentischer und cochem-zell
alkoholiker mal hierhin und verbindungen
fangen wir nur mit gabeln verkrampfen
erstmal von der bildung keiner geht
nicht auf die wattflächen mit einem
hinter seiner freundin reden führer
dürfte um sich besser empfunden machen
wir wenn auch die ein bisschen die total
wird nun für angewandte die übelsten
[Musik]
versperrt immer alle träume in
manchester gab schon vermitteln
angestimmt aber macht meinte gerade die
kicker aus dem kleinen falcon und heller
jene mitte zu sehen es ja unter hammer
geil aussieht schon geil aus alter ich
schon geil die pizza ist komplett fertig
das halt ich schneide jetzt nochmal rein
schneider das erste stück abschneiden
und ihr sieht schon dafür ist das stück
von unsere schokoladen egal ob das
könnte ein richtiger facebook
importieren wie die luft geschickt auf
die in meinem freund von reichen
freunden leute wenn ihr das ganz
begeistert weil ich meine schaut euch
doch mal an wert das ist einfach eine
schokolade pizza eltern schickt das
video euren freunden und zeigte ihnen
potter ist geiler herren und diese pizza
ist geil und verbrechern und lassen
leichter die pid ist gerade noch sehr
sehr heiß ich würde sagen ich nehme
jetzt ein kleines stück kinderschokolade
und probiere da und verdient nicht nur
lecker und ist anbieter von de muro
probiert alter hammer geil
so wird schon wissen was ihr von dem
teig bei der tg perfekt machte sich mehr
auf seine schokoladen torte so ein
bisschen aber im kompletten jetzt
zweimal rettete sagte zu probieren
wir haben jetzt die hitze am start
ich würde sagen auch die schokoladen ist
die erste die ich gemacht habe
also 4
der in kuchen für die kinder
funktioniert überraschend gut aber ich
bin es schmeckt märchen kuchen alles
wird man mit bernd müller für schokolade
pizza und ich muss sagen ich bin
überrascht wenn er vorher gesagt mich
dass mir die intel-aktie ekelhaften als
möglich und klar aber ich habe jetzt
noch nicht diese dr oetker schüco pizza
probieren aber heute sagen wie hier
kommt dem ganze schon recht natürlich
probieren
im restaurant so als nachts hört und
bestellen oder sagen wir mit komplette
hitler davon kann glaube ich nicht essen
aber ich bin auch ein fan mails für
deren komplette packung schokolade
wright war den wir von unseren versucht
eine schokoladen bezahlten stellen wenn
die wirklich von doppelter in dem laden
raus gekommen ist dann werde ich
natürlich auch mal ne quittung würden
sagen angeschnitten aber ich zeige euch
nochmal ganz kurzen kleine form von der
islam
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das video mit einer verbesserten leiter
schickt euren freunden gefallener
abonnierten kanal dafür den emittierten
da vorne findet nämlich einen smiley
eingeblendet wenn die optik abonniert
mich mein alter oben bin ich auch einen
stoff eingeblendet und hier schwingt mir
empfang das läuft schreiben können sie
ja auch gesehen dass mark uns gewinnt
der online video komplett auch schäfer
scheiterte